nous avons appris hier la disparition de
celui à qui qui a révolutionné le saut
en hauteur Dick fossbury afin de lui
rendre hommage en ce moment même si ça
vous intéresse des stands éphémères sont
installés un peu partout dans la
capitale et dans certaines villes
françaises pour ceux qui seraient tentés
de reproduire ce célèbre fausse Berry
c'est en tournant le dos à l'obstacle
qu'il a marqué l'histoire finale du saut
en hauteur des Jeux olympiques de Mexico
en 1968 Dick Fosbury s'apprête à
franchir sa première barre le stade va
basculer dans une nouvelle ère
avec ce saut et son passage sur le dos
une technique inédite qui permet ce
jour-là à l'Américain de décrocher l'or
avec une barre de mètres 24 on se
connecte tout de suite dans le deuxième
arrondissement de Paris ou Régis serlink
va tenter de réaliser un phosbury pour
se rendre au bureau il a l'air déterminé
allez Régis on y croit on y va c'est
parti
à suivre dans la prochaine demi-heure de
première édition une nouvelle série
Netflix vous connaissez Emily in pourri
c'est la grève des éboueurs qui
continuent à Paris plus de 5500 tonnes
de poubelles non ramassées depuis 8
jours et nos équipes ont pu filmer cette
nuit figurez-vous des camions bennes
privés qui collectent les ordures en
catimini dans certains arrondissements
et puis dans un instant on va aussi
parler des de la Corse
Paris la Tour Eiffel le Louvre les
Champs-Élysées Paris les rats les
surmulos les ratatouille Paris les
senteurs les parfums les effluves
bienvenue dans la capitale wALCOM il
part in Paris
aurait rêvé avoir leur image de tas de
poubelles mais ils ne l'ont pas eu
résultat ils ont enrobés comme ici à
Nantes regardez le résultat le voici il
faut se la Lomé entre les déchets par
endroits pour pouvoir passer sur le
trottoirs et une barquette de la parler
de slalom Paris Anne ma sœur Anne ne
sont rien venir il y avait des
embouteillages il y avait des pistes
cyclables il y avait la crasse il y a
désormais le pourri la varié le croupie
i'm sorry where is the airport
chère Anne Hidalgo ne changez rien c'est
en 2016 elle était sur BFM voilà elle
était sur RMC BFM TV c'était avec
Jean-Jacques Bourdin on est en pleine
contestation de la loi de la loi travail
François Hollande était au pouvoir les
une partie des poubelles parisiennes
encore n'étaient pas bloqué voilà ce que
était bloqué voilà ce que disait Madame
la Maire de Paris nous avons pu accéder
au garage dans lesquels sont les camions
Ben qui permettent leur ramassage des
ordures à Paris monsieur que pensez-vous
de ce mouvement de grève
nous infliger injuste parce que les
ministres dites le média à ce que les
ministres ils croient que c'est la faute
d'Annie Dago et de son équipe s'il y a
des poubelles dans les rues merci
beaucoup nous avons mobilisé la collecte
privée le secteur privé pour venir nous
aider à résorber où cette existant qui
n'est pas tolérable et je l'ai dit je ne
veux pas que la ville soit
d'abord il y a l'image mais il y a aussi
confort et puis le confort oui la
question de sécurité également bien sûr
toutes les ordures seront ramassées et
là voilà là maintenant la solution la
grève elle existe elle est testée depuis
quelques années entre autres par Volvo
c'est le camion poubelle autonome sans
intervention humaine le camion poubelle
il se met à la cuisine alors il va pas
venir dans votre cuisine non mais il
peut venir sur le pas de votre porte et
récupérer de manière complètement
autonome c'est comme une voiture
autonome il se débrouille tout seul il
se débrouille dans il analyse son
environnement il détecte une poubelle
sur le bas-côté il s'arrête et là vous
avez alors pour les tests c'est un être
humain mais vous pouvez avoir des petits
robots qui vont sortir de l'arrière du
véhicule se saisir de la poubelle les
mettre dans la benne moi j'ai honte
vraiment
si vous avez des amis qui viennent des
des touristes qui viennent enfin l'image
de Paris que vous donnez à travers cette
séquence et me paraît complètement folle
quoi une nouvelle fois il y a que chez
nous que ça existe vous allez aux
États-Unis
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre priorité sécuriser le parcours de
la manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites de demain à la demande de la
préfecture de police les poubelles ont
été ramassées sur l'itinéraire du
cortège pour que les déchets ne
deviennent pas des dangers ça peut être
incendiés ou alors ça peut servir de
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre et
effectivement on peut avoir des
manifestants qui qui glissent sur les
sur les objets qui sont laissés comme ça
sur le trottoir à Toulouse la CGT a
carrément organisé une coupure de
courant pour protester contre la réforme
des retraites quelques 30 000 logements
et commerces du centre-ville ont été
privés de l'électricité aux alentours de
midi la coupure a duré 40 minutes
pendant lesquelles la circulation des
tramway a été interrompu écouté
aujourd'hui on a ciblé la préfecture qui
est qui est pour nous le représentant le
plus proche pour nous de l'État céline
est arrivé en retard
il y avait des bouchons de la Bourgogne
enfin elle va raconter n'importe quoi
j'étais chez maman à Chalon-sur-Saône
qu'est-ce que vous faites comme boulot
je suis planificatrice où ça
à la SNCF il reste 500 jours avant les
Jeux olympiques de Paris et beaucoup de
questions sur la billetterie les
infrastructures la sécurité et puis une
autre question qui n'est pas encore
tronché il y aura-t-il des athlètes
russes voilà beaucoup de questions à se
poser alors que le compte à rebours est
lancé sommes-nous prêts pour accueillir
à Paris cet événement planétaire on pose
la question à Jean-Philippe Leclerc le
directeur adjoint la rédaction de
l'équipe par nos Patrick dans tout de
suite non on n'est pas prêt je vous
remercie